There is a new poll of Ohio voters done by
the right leaning Rasmussen Reports, which
has Donald Trump losing by four points to
Joe Biden, 49 to 45.
And this is a really important poll for a
few different reasons.
First of all, is Ohio.
Ohio is of such importance to Republicans
and in fact, Republicans.
A Republican presidential candidate has not
won the Electoral College without winning
Ohio.
Dating back decades.
You have to go at least to the 70s.
And I didn't go back any further than that.
So Republicans need Ohio historically in order
to win, even more so than, I would even say,
Florida.
Ohio is one of those states where if Trump
does not win Ohio, it could be a very, very
bad election for Donald Trump.
This is also an important poll because it's
a Rasmussen poll and Rasmussen polls tend
to lean right.
If even a Rasmussen poll says Trump is losing
Ohio by four.
That could also be very bad for Trump.
However, you might say this is only one poll.
Donald Trump certainly is still winning Ohio
overall, right?
Not so fast.
In fact, in the real Clear Politics average
of recent polling, Joe Biden is up by two
point four on average right now in Ohio.
That includes an Ohio media collaborative
poll from six weeks ago which had Joe Biden
winning it.
There's a poll between that one and the Rasmussen
poll, which has Donald Trump up by one.
So it is certainly true that there's not as
much polling data out of Ohio as there is
from some other states.
It is absolutely a fact that we should not
get cocky or arrogant in any way.
But this is much like, you know, when we look
at Donald Trump being up by only two in Texas,
according to the recent Dallas Morning News
poll.
When you look at the numbers out of places
like Arizona, these are signals about how
the election could go if we vote, if that's
all it is.
These are when I see a poll, I see it as an
opportunity.
And it actually would make a lot of sense
if Ohio went to Joe Biden.
It would make sense because Ohio has been
absolutely ravaged by Donald Trump's tariffs
on China, which I know you all understand
this.
Trump doesn't seem to when you place tariffs
on Chinese products, American businesses importing
those products pay the tariffs.
It's not the Chinese who pay the tariffs when
you're in manufacturing, when you're in farming
and you're dealing with counter tariffs from
China.
Ohio is a place that would be very much affected
by Donald Trump's disastrous trade policy.
The point here is every state has to be involved.
We're going to deal with this in today's voicemail.
In fact, I'm continuing to experience worry
that some people aren't getting the importance
of every state being involved here.
But think about it this way.
If Donald Trump is really up by only two in
Texas.
Make him fight for the win.
Make him spend money in Texas that he won't
have other places.
We talked yesterday about how Donald Trump
has already spent 73 percent of the one point
one billion dollars that he's raised since
the start of 2019.
Trump is in a cash crunch.
Trump is struggling to continue running ads
in all of the states in which he should be
running ads, make him spend money to defend
Texas.
If Florida is tied or Bidens up a little in
Florida or Trump is up a little in Florida,
the point is Florida is in play and any money
that Trump spends in Florida is money he cannot
spend in Ohio.
That's good for Joe Biden.
The whole point here is we have to run up
the score in every state while simultaneously
keeping the pressure up.
So Trump actually has to fight for states
that in past elections, Republicans didn't
have to put any money into.
That would have been easy wins for Republicans.
That's the way to do it.
One other great example of this is Arizona.
Arizona has been a red state for a long time
and in presidential elections.
And on average, Joe Biden is currently winning
by five, including winning by nine in Arizona.
In a recent Fox News poll, Martha McSally,
the Republican incumbent senator in Arizona,
is down by as much as 17.
Two Democratic Senate challenger, Mark Kelly.
It tells us nothing other than the state is
in play and it's worth fighting for, if only
to make Donald Trump himself have to fight
for it.
That in itself helps Joe Biden.
Let's keep it going.
We're down to just seven plus weeks remaining
here.
We're going to keep the pressure up.
We need you to keep the pressure up as well.